раніше циpка в санаторій тепер тут
накладаються завиє і рани війни
українські то російські скроні та
розумно суть службу в стильному центрі з
контролю to coordinate та припаяні не
пам'ятаю
в середині українці проводити ран кого
липучку
зараз бою з протестом їх тобто зачепивши
безпілотники
пряма
розгоратися головне завдання цех ризикових
контроль за пропан та ним у вогні swits та
до лінії розмежування лише й кілька
хвилин машину та за десять кілометрів вигляд
лінії фронту дачі
Тетяна гаврилова переїхала сюди кілька
місяців тому подали лінії у вогні
лавина і тут про себе нагадала прямим
попаданням струменевого та будди ну-ка
йдіть на щастя на той момент
нікого не було в будинку
нам би тільки не стріляв і вже все
одне а бути аль-Кайда лежить з путіну
тому що ціни жити а циклу пораниш і
Тетяна жила тут тепер буду і став ніг
з страшним порожнім з пиво hipster без
це українська вся кава в стані вив і
треба [ __ ] відеокамери
жерці ви дно висік кований dometic
прийшли нові на якщо не esit konami
українські то російські всю каву в
соледар записувати за видами lanevids
пустирі гачів проби2 бог і кордон у сема
відомі ти довіряєш
обама сторони ми проти стильно робота
не прирікай ви ікл для українців
для монет і 10 доладно там ще ми знаємо
їжте і російська агресія проти
україни складно було прила матриця б
психологічно в тему харчування
вся кава у солоді ретримаються astron
види інтерв'ю повідомляються на адже
битва находять строєм і пунктом про брата
не з українцями в їхньому розумі юний травня